perfetto bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
questo video sono fa vj e oggi parliamo
di cose ormai non sarà che videocamere
intro perché adesso diventa niente atp
serie quindi trovano entro vogliamo
ragazzi di un argomento di cui si è
parlato tantissimo
però proviamo ad analizzare un punto di
vista differente senza cadere nello
scontato poi magari saremmo scontati lo
stesso spero di no però proviamo ad
analizzare un punto di vista differente
sull'argomento del rating del quale si è
già straparlato penso di poterne parlare
anche io ho visto che comunque i primi
anni su youtube sono stati
pregni dieting e parliamo proprio di
questo cos'è lighting per chi non lo
sapesse aver semplicemente una persona
che va a scrivere un commento negativo
spesso insultando non facendo critiche
negative tipo dovresti migliorare questo
no ad una persona io parlo strettamente
di chi fa contenuti sul web perché poi
c'è letti poi si parla anche di bullismo
queste cose qua c'è se no non finiamo
mai più però parlo strettamente della
mia esperienza sul web ok la grande
domanda è come non come superare
lighting ok quindi tutti ma l'hanno
sempre fatta me l'ha fatta io toby
continua a farmela aiuti olio toby nel
rating come si come l'ho superato io io
semplicemente dic ho la fortuna la ford
perché è una fortuna mi reputo
abbastanza sveglio da capire che il
parere di una persona che non conosco
non può ferirmi perché non è niente
quella persona per me come se voi per
strada state facendo la cacca in un
cespuglio che vi passa un cane vi vede
fare la cacca nel cespuglio ok non vi
prendete male è un cane va bene se
invece mi guardasse fare la cacca mio
cugino oppure che ne so familiare quello
che mi imbarazzerebbe tantissimo io
quindi di carattere per me una persona
che non conosco che mi dà del
è come se un cane mi stessa abbaiando
non fa niente il problema è che dovete
essere così di carattere questo che io
ma riuscito a spiegare a karim aiuto b
chiama regalmente quindi non stiamo a
parlare di come superare lei king come
sempre nei video ma parliamo invece
del perché c'è
sting ok allora innanzitutto io credo
che lei thing e sono tutti i pareri miei
personali e non sono fatti per insultare
later che questo momento non è nessuno
si parla delle teen generale lighting è
dato da un quoziente intellettivo
secondo me nettamente basso perché una
persona
e hite riza qualcuno quando quel
qualcuno sa qualcosa che quella persona
non ha questa è la maggior parte delle
volte ok c'è hating anche sulle persone
che vanno a fare il grande fratello i
cronisti i cronisti dicendo che a queste
persone non hanno un briciolo di
cervello perché quello che leggo online
e 15 le lighting ma non è per questo che
c'hai lighting lighting c'è perché
quelle persone hanno tanto seguito
nonostante la loro poca cioè loro non
saper fare
nonostante il loro non essere artisti in
realtà è questo che crea e ting perché
se tu vedessi una persona che reputo una
persona stupida ok non lo vai a scrivere
su internet dove si lavora è proprio
stupido e lo reputo stupido no perché
perché tu ti dovresti accanire con una
persona che è inferiore a te ok
pensatore a pitture putin stupido una
persona perché tutti i tipi intelligente
perché ovviamente qualcuno e si reputo
ancora più stupido di quello che sta
insultando dalla sarebbe un idiota ha
elevato all'ennesima potenza che sta
insultando 1 e tu sei peggio quindi
tutti reputi superiore a quella persona
lì se non avrebbe senso ed è proprio
questo il fatto c'è nel senso delle
persone non riescono a capire o non
vogliono capire che non vogliono capire
cosa c'è dietro al lavoro in questo caso
che magari ho fatto io quindi tornando
sul discorso senza andar off topic 1
apriva il mio video su youtube vedeva un
ragazzino che urlava e sbraitava quando
succedeva un qualcosa un jump square una
roba del genere no negli horror dieci
minuti di video e ero e roma ero
diventato famoso così e quindi a questo
qua urla
che diventavano kay quindi questo
secondo me e quoziente intellettivo
basso ma c'è un motivo non è un insulto
violo credo fortemente quella persona
sia così infatti
per quello anche non mi crea problemi
oltre che per il fatto che non lo
conosco perché non ci arriva a capire
che cosa c'è di a cosa c'è dietro e le
cose le persone guardano il risultato
finale un film tu guardi un film una
persona media media intendo una persona
non ragiona sulle cose vede un film di
ciò che è bello non è che sa che dietro
c'è regia sceneggiatura fotografia
studi ci sono miliardi di persone che
hanno lavorato nel dietro le quinte i
prof
gli accordi to miliardo di cose che c'è
dietro un lavoro che tu vedi finito e
che dura un'ora e mezza ma è durato una
vita e ha coinvolto un miliardo di
persone nella realizzazione di quella
cosa lì ok tu non lo sai tu vedi solo
risultato finale le cose su youtube è
amplificata questa cosa perché non è
neanche un film vedi uno che davanti una
camera dice questo sta parlando e basta
quindi perché dovrebbe essere conosciuto
è fallo tu e la risposta banale che
danno tutti è perchè non lo fai te e qui
da qui si aprono è ma per chi non lo
voglio fare
ovviamente se quella persona facesse
quella roba lì si accorgerebbe che c'è
un mare di cose ok poi magari lo fai lo
pubblichi e non hai successo perché i
tralasciato un miliardo di cose quindi
qual è il vero problema di tutto questo
è che le persone parlano ma non sanno ok
perché se sapessero non parlerebbero in
questo modo quindi l'unica cosa che
potete fare nel vostro caso e ignorare
chi non merita l'attenzione perché non
la merita veramente non è che il nome
che lo sto vendendo anno non la meritano
non guardateli non la meritano davvero
cioè capite assimilate questa cosa
cercate di farvela entrare dentro non lo
merita perché davvero non lo merita
perché non ci dovreste spendere
attenzioni per una persona che non vuole
capire che non è interessata a capire è
come voi parlate con uno che guarda il
cielo mentre voi state guardo bard
mentre voi state parlando
non vi sta ascoltando quanto potreste
andare avanti con questa conversazione
sta guardando il cielo non vi sta
realmente ascoltando anche se vi sta
rispondendo quindi parlate al muro poi
tra l'altro aggiungiamo che in questo un
parere mio ma l'italia è ancora più
indietro secondo me riguardo alle thing
è stata molto indietro degli altri paesi
perché per standardizzare il fatto che i
creator sul web fosse un lavoro ci
abbiamo messo anni ok cio nel 2014 2015
andavo a los angeles molto spesso per le
tre per lavori che ho fatto dei tre più
svariati e vedevo i cartelloni
pubblicitari degli youtubers sui palazzi
ok vedevo i cartelloni degli youtubers
perché l'america spingeva i propri
youtubers in italia neanche a un lavoro
ancora adesso fatichiamo a capire che lo
youtube era un lavoro e ci stiamo aree
ci siamo ormai quasi arrivati direi
ormai ci siamo ma siamo nel 2021 ok in
america sono arrivati dieci anni fa sta
cosa ed era già standardizzato quindi
secondo me noi ancora fatichiamo stiamo
navigando nel fango nel pongo nelle
sabbie mobili e difficile fare dei passi
avanti ma si fanno ok quindi prendete
atto del fatto che siamo in italia e le
cose arrivano più lentamente va bene ma
questo per quanto riguarda i creators
per quanto riguarda invece lighting sul
web e generalizzato penso di essermi
espresso già abbastanza concludo dicendo
che questo di base quindi è una
questione più che altro di età nel senso
che se tu sei piccolo ok più piccolo 6
più non capisci quanto in realtà una
persona che ha successo può avere altri
problemi nel senso che io non posso
invidiare una persona capi successo di
me perché potrebbe avere molti più
problemi di me perché la vita non è
fatta solo di denaro e fama ok è fatta
di tantissime cose fatta di amici di
relazioni di salute fatta di tantissime
cose e tutte queste che ho detto per me
sono superiori al denaro e la fame tra
l'altro quindi invidiare una persona per
queste cose qua più di venti grande più
prendi coscienza di che cosa vuol dire
vivere e più capisci che invidiare una
persona non ha senso perché non sai in
realtà quella persona quali altre cose
non sa che invece tu hai ok che poi
anche se quella persona avesse tutto se
fosse felice non avrebbe senso odiarlo
allo stesso perché che cosa ti porta a
te odiare una persona che sa più di
quello che tu non niente c'è quindi non
avrebbe senso quindi se una persona
fosse felice io sarei felice per lui che
felice quindi non è che cambia niente
però a maggior ragione per le persone
che sono abituato ad odiare più crescono
e più capiscono che c'è altro oltre
ora fa ma io ovviamente sto dicendo sto
parlando solo di chi insulta quindi
proprio dell'odio non di chi a pareri
contrastanti ovviamente voi potete per
farvi un esempio voi potreste non essere
d'accordo con le mie parole di nino favi
stai sbagliando secondo me perché
secondo me è così questo non c'entra
niente c'è questa è critica questo e
dibattito queste tutto un altro discorso
cioè ovviamente sto parlando solo
dell'odio fine a se stesso quindi un
cane che abbaia lo lascia abbagliare un
iter che utilizza lo lasci e iterare
vuoi farla ingelosirla non so quanto
fosse corretta grammaticalmente quella
frase ma non la rifaccio perché concetto
era buono quindi peace and love questa
cosa mi sembra abbastanza scontata visto
che
voi siete sicura voi avete sicuramente
un quoziente intellettivo sopra alla
media quindi non e non fate eating
rating perché nessuno deve miliare
nessuno ognuno c'ha la propria vita
ognuno ha i propri atti propri bassi in
diversi ambiti quindi io auguro a tutti
voi di avere sempre alti come al solito
fatemi sapere che cosa ne pensate
ragazzi di questo discorso nei commenti
fatemi sapere se avete avuto delle
esperienze cose del genere ma ho parlato
solo delle eating del web è perché poi
c'è tutto un altro discorso
però parlo solo di quello che può
esserci nei confronti di un creatore di
qualcuno che porta dei contenuti ok
quindi di chi ha successo in generale
fatemi sapere iscrivetevi al canale
lasciate un mi piace e civile
[Musica]